okay so good morning everyone now that I
can't see anyone that's much better
with these lights so welcome to my talk
about kernel development with modern C++
I didn't make any thorough check but I
think there was never a kernel socket
NDC anywhere anytime so that's a record
actually was very surprised that the
talk was accepted and so kind of weird
being here talking about kernel but I
see a few people so we see how many we
will we will be left at the end of the
talk okay so my name is Pavel I'm a
developer I'm a trainer I'm an author
and apparently a speaker and so I've
written a few books the latest one is
about Windows kernel development and so
some of the stuff I'll describe today is
actually some things I've done as part
of my current development I like to like
to write in kernel mode I like using
mode as well using what this is
perfectly fine but kernel has kind of
it's a special thing special power and
maybe special aura maybe and so I've
written some other books so again as
always go ahead and buy them that's very
good for me so go ahead and do that
I have several open source tools on
github and a few blogs you might want to
read so what what what is it about what
I'm going to talk about in this session
so the idea is that in kernel classic
development drivers or kernel drivers
were always written in C and so this is
kind of the hard core this is how
low-level code should look like C is the
real language everything else is just
those layers of abstractions that
probably hurt performance and more
memory allocations and who knows what so
you should always use seen if you're
really one of those brave souls assembly
language is really the best but as a
compromise you can use C and I'm talking
from experiencing the Windows and
Microsoft space and so if you look at
the samples for drivers that Microsoft
provides on github they're all written
in C even today but in fact you can use
C++ and it actually can
help create drivers that are more robust
because as I'll describe shortly in
kernel-mode you're less likely to be
forgiven for mistakes one of the fatal
mistakes that everybody knows about in
Windows is that blue screen of death
that everybody likes and so this blue
screen happens when there is an
exception in kernel mode that is
unhandled in user mode well the process
crashes you can continue moving on in
kernel mode everything crashes and so
you have to be extra careful in the
kernel and so using C++ this as I try to
demonstrate can actually make your code
more robust less likely to crash and
less likely to leak resources and so I'm
going to show you some examples of
course this is not a crash course in
writing kernel drivers if you are
expecting to write kernel drivers after
this talk you'll be disappointed for
sure but just to give you some ideas of
what you can do and how to think about
these things to create more robust code
which of course is good for other
low-level code maybe embedded code not
necessarily something running in the
kernel and so classically Microsoft
didn't support C++ at all for kernel
development officially until 2012
up until then you had to use C if you
wanted to get any support from Microsoft
so people actually did use light
lightweight C++ like the ability to
declare variable anywhere not just the
beginning of scopes so this was actually
fixed in c99 the Microsoft compiler
didn't support that so you actually had
to declare everything upfront but it was
unsupported so you couldn't get official
support from Microsoft if you have any
issues for whatever reason unrelated to
C++ but starting with 2012 Microsoft
actually decided they're going to
support developing with C++ and the
compiler compiling your code is the same
compiler that is bundled today with
Visual Studio and again that wasn't the
case previously you had a different
compiler for drivers and different
compiler for using
which was kind of silly they're all C++
compilers why should they actually be
different but now thankfully it's
supported officially but still as I
mentioned the samples that Microsoft
provides some of these samples are
actually the actual code of some drivers
that are in Windows are still written in
pure C which i think is a shame the
kernel by the way in Windows is written
mostly in C but there is actually one
piece which uses C++ it only owns or
it's always makes me kind of laugh a
little bit because there is one process
that you will not see in task manager
it's called memory compression memory
compression is a process that's
available starting with Windows 10 the
rs1 version version 6007 the anniversary
update where Windows actually can
compress physical memory to conserve
space now task manager if you open that
and look for memory compression it's not
there because there's a specific calling
task manager that says if it's that
memory compression let's just continue
not show it why because people may see
the memory compression process consuming
lots of memory they'll say what's that
junk I mean who is consuming dot memory
but in fact this is compress memory so
it's actually saving memory but people
don't realize that with casual looks so
if you go ahead and either look at the
memory tab for instance you can see that
currently on my machine does 10.8
gigabytes of RAM used but I have 595
megabytes which is compressed memory
which means that I'm saving them or
maybe they're the uncompressed memory is
1 gigabyte and I'm only consuming far
have 595 megabytes so it's a good thing
however if you look at different tools
such as process Explorer process
Explorer does not hide anything and here
you can find the memory compression
process it does exist you can see that
it's consumption is actually the same as
the number of megabytes we've seen
earlier if you go ahead and double click
that and look at the threads tab you'll
see a code here that is part of pointy
or scanner which is the Windows kernel
you can see it's C++ not
C++ but it uses templates I actually saw
this source code in person when I was
working for Microsoft for a brief period
and I was actually amazed that the store
manager which is the component that's
managing the memory compression
infrastructure is actually written in
C++ and uses templates the rest of the
kernel uses pure C know C++ at all and
certainly not templates so someone there
and actually know who did that so kind
of impressive but their own drivers are
still using pure C okay so what's
different about user mode versus Karamel
development what's really different I
mean why should we do anything different
in kernel mode than we're doing in user
mode and so first there was the thing I
mentioned earlier about unhindered
exceptions if you have an exception it's
not handled in user mode then that
particular process crashes so it's
probably not very pretty but it's not
too bad either your system is intact you
can just go about your business maybe
you had some bug you can correct that
everything is good
however in kernel mode only bug is
causing the system to crash with that
blue screen by the way the blue screen
is not Microsoft's punishment on
developers it's not that it's really a
mechanism to protect the system because
kernel code is trusted or supposed to be
trusted because it's all-powerful you
can do anything you can actually make
some damage that will prevent Windows
from restarting and so the purpose of
the blue screen is to stop right now so
that any further code will not be able
to cause any potential damage and so you
have to code very carefully in kernel
mode much more than in user mode another
thing that is different is that in user
mode when a process terminates for
whatever reason maybe normally maybe
because it was terminated forcefully
maybe because an unhandled exception
happened doesn't matter the operating
system cleans up everything so all the
private memory is freed all the handlers
are closed
Natha
thing is left that is guaranteed in user
mode however if you have a driver and
you allocated some memory for instance
and when a driver unload you forgot for
whatever reason to deallocate that
memory no one will do that for you
and so you lick memory until the next
restart so you may wonder why is the
kernel not kind of tracking all these
memory locations and just freeing them
when the appropriate driver unloads and
so the reason is that it's simply too
dangerous because it may be the case
that the driver left that memory on
purpose because it's talking to another
driver that is going to use that memory
to do something else and so if the
kernel would release that memory the
other driver will access memory that is
not there and we're going to crash the
system so the kernel can't really take
any chances and that's why it's not
tracking any memory locations and it
will not free any memory automatically
and remember that in kernel space all
the drivers are in one address space
this is different than in user mode
where each process has its own address
space and there don't they don't mix so
it's very easy theoretically to
communicate between two drivers because
they are running in the same space so
again you need to be careful not to lick
anything because otherwise this leak
will only be resolved in the next boot
now what about the return values from
functions so if you're calling Windows
API is in user mode they return some
value telling you whether you succeed or
not and some developers say well I'm
calling this function it's a very low
probability that we would ever fail
they're not checking return values for
every function checking for return
values for functions that seem to have
maybe the chance at least days it to
fail but in kernel mode is very very
important to always check for errors
you cannot really miss anything because
anything can can happen even if you're
trying to allocate let's say 10 bytes
which seems like a very small amount of
memory you can't really take the chance
because this could fail maybe the system
is now very long on resources the driver
is in a system that it doesn't control
so anything can happen you should always
check for return values from functions
or various api's there's something
called an interrupt request level which
we don't have time to talk in detail
this is a term that if you if you have
been doing any user mo development
you've never heard of that's completely
fine because in user mode the value of
AI RQL is always zero for all processors
and so there's no point in introducing a
new term when it's never changing and it
doesn't affect you but in kernel mode
the RQL can be higher and when article
goes to the value of 2 or higher this
puts some constraints on the way on the
things that you can do in the kernel so
in our ql2 you actually get to a use
memory which must be resident in RAM if
the memory is paged out for whatever
reason you're going to blue screen the
system you cannot wait for kernel
objects there's no way to wait because
the scheduler is asleep and cannot wake
on that particular processor so there's
some very strict limitations on this
type of code and so you again have to be
extra careful so generally if you have
some bad coding for for from whatever
reason they're more likely to be
affecting the entire system when you
have a driver because the driver
typically services many processes and if
the driver dead locks or something like
that it could deadlock many processes
and so again you have to be extra
careful when you're testing or debugging
using what applications you just a chat
attach your debugger to a process and
then just debug it very simple on your
developer machine everything is nice and
cozy in kernel mode you can't really do
that if you want to debug a driver you
have to debug a different machine it
could be a virtual machine but it must
be a different machine and so when you
set a breakpoint you actually freeze the
entire machine there's no way to debug a
particular process on the other machine
you debug a machine and so the debugging
is is more calm
flex and more time-consuming and that's
why you probably don't want that many
bugs in your driver because it just
makes everything take longer so what
about the various libraries that you
know and perhaps love so in user mode
you can use any C++ or C library under
the Sun that you can find in car mode
you can't use them you can't use most of
them if not all and I'll show you why in
in the next few slides exceptions so in
C++ in classical C++ you can use throws
statements to throw exceptions you can
catch them with try catchin and all
these things but you can do any of that
in the kernel because in the current
there is no C++ runtime there is no C++
runtime and that has several
implications one of them that you cannot
use the classic exception handlers and
so Microsoft provides its own mechanism
for exception handling this is part of
the kernel called structured exception
handling which is also available in user
mode by the way and so if you want to
take advantage of exception handling you
actually have to use some extensions to
the C language to provide to get
yourself those proper keywords to be
able to catch exceptions but of course
these are not high-level exceptions
these are not objects that are being
thrown these are just numerical values
with some parameters so if you want to
handle exceptions in kernel mode seh is
your only option there is nothing else
and so the bottom line is you don't have
a runtime so what does that mean so for
example let's say you have global
variables and so global variables may
have constructors and so if you're
walking in user mode when your main
function starts to execute all those
global variables were already
initialized so someone had to call all
the Constructors and this is in fact
done by the C runtime so the C runtime
is actually the first thing relatively
that user-mode code that is running and
it's the one calling your constructors
and then calling your main function so
there's something there but in caramel
you don't have that there is no C++
runtime so no one is there to call your
global object constructors which really
means you can't use them so you can't
use global objects that have
constructors maybe you can just define a
pointer and then allocate them
dynamically this is something you can do
and I will show you how to do that but
you still have to do some work because
the new operator isn't supported as well
because again this is part of the C++
runtime and you doesn't have any
implementation in the kernel but because
you can overload that you can fix that
okay so this is kind of some of the
constraints that we have in the color so
there's no runtime and that means I have
to take care of some things that will
not be taken care of otherwise however
most of the C++ features that you know
actually work just fine in the kernel
because they're just compiler mechanisms
so stuff like Auto and lambda functions
rate based force templates work just
fine as we've seen the kernel itself is
using template so they must be working
you can have move semantics you can
overload operators so everything
normally available to the supastarz
developer from the language itself is
available so anything that is not
dependent on the runtime works just fine
it just can simply use it so just to
kind of make this more concrete we're
working in that yellow box at the top
that's the kernel space on 64-bit
systems
that's an address space of 128 terabytes
so of course the current doesn't consume
on that memory otherwise it will not
exist but this is just a range of
addresses that the kernel can use and
drivers that are there can use so they
are kind of running together in that one
big community called kernel space where
as processors each one has its own
potential 128 terabytes of memories so
communication between processes is more
difficult because they have their own
address spaces but communication between
drivers for instance is relatively
simple because these addresses at the
top are absolute they look the same form
whatever process you're looking at okay
so I want to start showing some code
examples of how we can leverage CPC
passes in the kernel to make our code
more robust and less likely to leak or
crash and so the first thing is
something that is definitely not new
something known as the Rye idiom in C++
or resource acquisition is
initialization which is a very bad name
but it is the name so people typically
use it so this is the classic C++
cleanup mechanism where you want to take
something and then you want to make sure
that something is released and so in the
kernel I think it's even more important
than in user mode because if you leak
something in user mode when that process
terminates eventually everything is
cleaned up but in the kernel that simply
doesn't happen until the next restart so
it's very important to make sure you
don't leak anything and of course some
types of leaks can actually and lead you
to a deadlock so let's see a one example
so let's say I'm using locks so I want
to use something like a mutex because I
need to protect some data structure from
concurrent access and so the classic
pattern here says I need to lock some
kind of mutex or acquired that mutex so
only one thread can acquire that mutex
and then continue execution and
accessing that shared data all other
threads trying to acquire the same mutex
at the same time will wait will go into
a wait state without spending CPU cycles
and team that first thread finishes
walking with the data to release the
mutex and one other thread just one can
acquire the mutex and go ahead and do
its own work with the shared data so
this is a general idea and we can
generalize this further by using
templates so
we have a class called auto-lock this is
very similar to the lock guard class in
standard C++ so actually I'm taking a
lot of lots of ideas from the standard
library that I know exists in user mode
which I can't use and just reimplemented
them maybe with some semantic changes to
fit my needs on my style but I'm trying
to get to something which is very
similar so you can see here I can I have
this auto lock and it's templatized on
whatever lock I want to use because
there are several types of locks that
are available in the kernel and I don't
want to create separate classes for
different types of locks and so I'm
accepting this T lock template parameter
and using that and storing reference to
the lock and and we can see here that
what I expect from that T log structure
is to have two functions lock and unlock
so don't care what that is and I'm using
that duck typing feature in C++
templates just bind to the proper
functions and so here's one example of a
mutex so in fact the classic mutex that
you know from a user mode is also
available in kernel mode but in car mode
there's another special mutex that is
not exported to user mode called the
fast mutex and it is a little bit faster
so one sense in which it's faster is
because it doesn't have ownership and so
it doesn't know which thread acquired it
which means you can't acquire that
recursively which you can do it with a
classic win32 API mutex and so here's my
mutex and has the lock and unlock
functions and that's good enough so
here's an implementation of that mutex
I'm using kernel api's to initialize the
mutex just once and then lock is going
to call the X acquire fast mutex
function this is the function in the
kernel that does the acquisition and
then release that same mutex in the
unlock function and now if I want to use
it it's very simple whenever I need to
acquire the mutex I can open even an
artificial scope if I wanted to to just
limit the mutex
handling just to the smallest scope I
can handle I'm just acquiring that and
then doing whatever needs to be done if
using C++ 17 which is fully supported by
the way you can remove that class name
because theta star 17 allows you to kind
of infer the type of template parameter
based on the parameter to the
constructor that my mutex thing so this
was added in C++ 17 and so this is the
one example and there are many other
examples and everything I'm trying to do
in the kernel that has this acquire and
release semantics maybe it's about
threading maybe it's about clocks maybe
it's about memory doesn't matter in
trying to create this wrapper classes so
here's another example about handles so
handles is something which is very
common in user mode and in kernel mode
in fact I used a very similar class in
my user mode development as well because
once you get a handle to whatever kernel
object you working with maybe handle to
a file handle to a mutex handle to a
semaphore to a process whatever you need
to close that handle as soon as you
don't need it and again if you don't
close the handle you'll lick the handle
and this is again eventually it
manifests itself is just using more
memory and in user mode so worst thing
when the process terminates then that
handle will be closed but in kernel mode
it will not and so I can create a class
called the generic handle which accepts
a handle for with whatever type of
handle I'm using there may be several
types of handles around and there is a
trait class this is one of the ways to
implement this idea and that traits
class is really holding a set of static
functions that do some specific things
such as giving me back what an invalid
handle means for for this particular
type of handle and I need to close the
handle I'm going to call a function
called closed on that traits object so
if I have a handle of one type maybe it
has one
type of function that closes that maybe
for a different type of handle there is
a different closing function and so I
can kind of encapsulate that by it
trades a trade class which is provided
here as as an argument and then I can
create some concrete trades and handle
classes so for example for classic
Colonel handles this is going to be the
trades the handle type is handle and so
I have this clause is valid and invalid
handle a functions that can plug in for
any handle that I need and so I can even
use using here and say kernel handle is
really generic handle with a type of
handle and these types of trades and I
have other other types of handles in a
similar fashion related to in this case
to file system mini filters but again
the idea here is that I don't have to
worry about releasing something when it
goes out of scope it will simply be done
so destructors are called normally no
problem there so rye is a classical
example and of course you should use it
in user mode just as in kernel mode
balcony mode is kind of little bit more
important so let's move on to memory
allocations and so in classic C++ using
the new and delete operators and as I
mentioned since we don't have any C++
runtime in a kernel this simply will not
compile and so what can we do about it
and of course the the classical answer
is let's override a new in delete and
provide our own implementation and so in
the kernel the way you work with i with
memory the at least one of the most
common ways to work with that is using
the kernel pools and so the kernel pools
can be used to allocate memory using
this main function X allocate pool with
tag which is very similar in concept to
something like malloc it says how many
bytes do you want to allocate I will
allocate that for you but there are two
other parameters here one of them is the
pool type so in kernel mode there are
actually two main pool types one of them
is called non page pool and the other is
called page pool so non page
is a very special pool in the sense that
everything you allocate there is
actually going to be in RAM and will
never be paged out you don't have that
power unusable but in kernel mode you
have and so if you need your data
structure to be available for example to
being able to access that in Oracle 2 or
higher which I briefly mentioned earlier
you want to allocate that from non page
pool in fact if you open task manager
again
you'll see here that we see here
something says page pool and non page
pool actually shows you how much memory
is consumed right now in the two types
of pools so the page pull is sort of
normal memory so some of that memory is
currently in RAM some that memories
paged out however the non page pool
means that 200 so in nine hundred and
something megabytes memory is currently
allocated from RAM and it's gone not
going anywhere so it's not not going to
be paged out and any time until the
driver that's responsible or the kernel
itself transport for that those
allocations will start freeing
allocations and so as opposed to malloc
I need to provide some information on to
which pool I want to make that
allocation from and then the last
parameter here was actually somewhat
optional is called the tag and the idea
of the tank is to mark my allocations
and so I mentioned that if I allocate
memory and I forget to free that when
the driver unloads nobody's going to
free that so how can I know if my driver
leaks memory or not so one classic way
of doing that it's not actually another
better way to do that today but the
classic way is to tag my allocations
with a four byte value comprised of
ASCII characters and then open some tool
to show me whether these characters
appear in the in the list of Pula
locations after my driver unloads so if
I don't find my tags I know I'm fine
I've released all memory if I find my
tag then obviously I haven't released
all the memory and so there are several
tools the
the classic tool is Pullman which is a
console based tool I hate it and so I
write my own version of of kernel pool
monitor so I actually wrote two versions
I'm going through the the second one and
this actually lists all the tags that
are currently used by the pool and each
one of these tags we can see information
about how many allocation has been done
what's the current consumption of page
or non page pool and this is updated
dynamically all the time we can also see
some information here in the source and
sauce description to understand from
which component this actually comes from
and so we can see many of these
allocations are coming from windows
itself so you can see her nti all for
instance this means this is the i/o
system of the i/o manager as part of the
kernel and so what the DRI typical
driver does attacks its allocation with
these up to fork ASCII characters to
distinguish himself from all other
drivers and kernel components and then
you can also look while the driver is
running what's going on with the
locations that the driver has been using
how much memory is he consuming how many
locations how many fries so this is all
tracked and we can use such a tool to
look at that and of course this is
available also when you walk in with a
kernel debugger and so what I want to do
is make sure that I call X allocate pool
and then I call X free pool whenever
that's needed and I don't forget that so
I need something that allows me to kind
of do that properly so one thing is
maybe creating some rye wrapper but
first I don't really want to call these
functions because maybe I want to
allocate memory for my own structure
that has a constructor and if it has a
constructor if I just call X allocate
pool with tag with the size of my
structure the constructor will not be
called and so I want to do something to
make it work and so the first option is
simply to override over all the new and
delete operators so we know that the new
operator can be of
overloaded and the first parameter must
be a size T but I can actually add more
parameters as many as I want
this is not a new feature this has been
available in C++ even in C++ 98 standard
and so because I need the pool type and
I need the tag I want to provide this as
part of my definition of the new
operator and I can of course define and
delete in similar manners there is an
example implementation so what i'm doing
here I'm calling X allocate pool if I
don't have any specific tag because then
the kernel provides a default tag or X
allocate pool with tag if the tag is not
0 and if I fail for whatever reason I'm
just issuing an output to the to the
debugger if it's attached and returning
that pointer so this is all I really
have to do because it's part of
operational calling the constructor is
part of the code the compiler will
inject automatically so I just need to
provide the compiler with the way to
actually allocate the memory the calling
to the constructor is going to be done
automatically by code injected by the
compiler so that simply works and then
all I need to do now is simply create my
own data structure whatever that may be
so here's my data data structure that
may contain sub objects they're made
themselves have constructors which is
definitely possible and I'm showing a
vector here which I'll discuss in a
moment and just doing a new operator
that looks like this so this is again
this syntax is not in new it it always
was available in C++ so new something
that something is my data but all the
extra parameters except for the size I
have to provide with parentheses before
the actual type so in this case I'm
saying I want to allocate my data object
from non page full and have some define
for driver target I provided earlier in
the code that would be one way of
working with that another way I can use
memory locations in this case is using
something which again is not new called
placement new placement new is the idea
that says the memory is already
allocated some entity allocated and
chunk of memory for my object but that
entity has no idea what's the purpose of
that block so it's just a set of bytes
so what I want to tell to the operator
new just call the constructor please
this is all I want the memory is already
there so this is exactly the point of
placement new so placement new looks
like this and the implementation is
trivial because I'm accepting to the
placement new the existing pointer where
the memory has already been allocated
all I need to do is just say okay that's
actually here and and again the the
benefit here is the compiler will add a
constructor call so I'm going to do a
new which actually allocates nothing
because the memory is already allocated
but the constructor will be called right
now and so how do I call the destructor
in this case but here's the call to the
new operator and so let's in this case
I'm calling X allocate pool with tag
explicitly but let's suppose I get a
pointer from some windows API some kind
of API that already allocated some
memory for me or maybe some other
component I have no idea how it a
located the memory perhaps but it is
allocated Ned nonetheless and so now I
just want to call the constructor to
initialize my object properly so I'm
doing new with the pointer and my data
notice I'm not even bothering capturing
the result because the result of that
new will be data itself so writing data
equals new data my data is really
useless I'm just using new data because
the pointer will not change this is
exactly what placement me returns the
existing pointer and so from the
perspective of releasing the memory I
need to call the destructor now
explicitly and so the only way I can do
that is by invoking the destructor
explicitly using the pointer itself this
is again this syntax is supported in C++
because there is no other way to do that
because I cannot call delete
here because it was not allocated by new
to us allocated by something else and so
I have to call the destructor and then D
allocate the memory explicitly using the
same function that the allocated memory
maybe some library function that I'm
calling now but this is the way I have
to work in order to actually invoke the
destructor so once I have these kind of
code in place I can go ahead and use new
delete one or this kind of code if I
have to so what else
what about strings strings are always
the fun no matter what library you using
use them other Kermode these libraries
tend to always invent new string types
have you noticed that that every library
you're using there's a new string type
every once I know all the other strings
are garbage I want to write my own
string type it's going to be better and
that's kind of always boggles the mind
there are so many strings out there in
user mode and so the kernel of course
has to have its own string type and the
way strings work in the Windows kernel
most of them is using a structure called
unicode string which has members too one
member is just pointing to an array of
characters and there are two members
saying what's the length of that string
and to make things a little bit harder
the length is in bytes not in characters
because unicode here really means utf-16
so we have two bytes per character so
the length is actually in bytes not in
characters which actually kind of
confuses some people and there's a
maximum length that indicates how much
that string can grow without doing any
special reallocation and of course this
is just a structure this is a sea
structure it has no special management
if you try to attend to that string
something that causes this the length to
be to more than a maximum length you're
screwed so you're going to probably blue
screen the system so you have to
relocate everything yourself and so the
first intuition in this case is saying
well maybe I should create a class that
would wrap unicode string
and that looks like a good idea but in
practice it doesn't really work that
well because this Unicode string the the
buffer itself the point of the buffer is
not necessarily owned by that string
maybe that pointer came from someone
else and that string just describes that
Bufferin so creating a class I tried
that actually that Rob's unicode string
made that class on what use almost
useless so it was I couldn't use it in
any good scenarios at least not without
getting confused when it's owning the
pointer and doesn't own the pointer kind
of looked bad so I decided to go another
way and do what everybody else does
create my own string type everybody's
doing it I can do it as well and so I
can create a string type so this is
always fun I mean you kind of going back
to your C++ basics where you create a
string type with a pointer to something
and maybe a length and then you create
all those operators and and kind of it's
I think it's fun sometimes to go back to
the basics and and and now you can do
whatever you want because you're not
constrained by any library don't have to
create your string to be exactly like
STD string in in user mode that's the W
string you can do anything you can do
whatever pleases you and you can provide
the API that you think is more intuitive
for whatever you're doing because this
is essentially just for you so just for
fun I created here a class called K
string and this class accepts a tag and
a pool type again because I'm going to
allocate dynamically a set of characters
and so I need to select the appropriate
pool so we can provide these parameters
as part of a template or maybe part of a
constructor so again this is a trade of
this is a design decision that you you
can do and then you can have various
constructors and operators and copy
constructors and move constructors and
whatever you need and to make it easier
to work with unicode strings i have a
function here that allows me to expose
that case string as a Unicode string you
these get unicode string function and so
if I have this function I'm accepting
Unicode string pointer form wherever I'm
simply filling in this is one way of
doing that initializing the members in
that unicode string to point to my
internal string that I'm managing and so
that unicode string is not going to be
the owner of the string I'm continuing
to own that string but any API that
needs unicode string I can provide that
and so this really made my life easier
when working with strings because I have
a simple string class it supports
operators and and all the other things
that strings typically support and
anytime I need to call an API in the
kernel that wants unicode string does
it's very easy to get one without
getting in into trouble
related to ownership things and of
course you can go ahead and do these
things for other types such as a vector
so a vector is again a very very popular
type in in user mode STD vector but is
using that and for good reason because
it's continuous in memory it's very fast
and so maybe I need these things in
kernel mode as well so I did that I
created a class called K vector again
templatized with with the pool type and
tag and so on and provided my own
operators for adding items to the vector
removing and so on so you have kind of
the the chance here to reinvent it's a
minimum standard library for your work
because there's nothing you can use that
is available you can try to get ideas
from existing libraries of course but of
course you don't have to you can do
whatever you want so let's look at
another example where we can do
something to ease our work in the kernel
and so the kernel uses a one very common
data structure to manage least at have
that can grow it to any size using a
linked list mechanism and so there is a
type called list entry which is just a
simple structure that has a pointer
forward in the pointer backwards so it
sort of the link in
linked list and so these points to
another object that has these pointers
and these points or another object and
so on and as you can see in the diagram
at the bottom we have some head to the
list which is taught in some management
structure and then we simply provide
these linked lists to elements and the
actual list entries the member inside
that data so this is one way of working
with linked lists and this is the way
the kernel works with its own linked
list and that API is completely
documented and so you driver writers can
use the same API and so if you have a
pointer to a list entry object how do
you get to the actual pointer to the
real structure that you care about and
so you need to do some pointer
arithmetic with the size and and the
offset of your entry inside that big
structure and so the kernel provides a
macro called containing record that
allows you to kind of take your pointer
your internal pointer to the actual list
entry and then get back the real pointer
with proper casting to your data
structure that you care about and so
this infrastructure already exists but
of course these items adding items
moving back items and so on you have to
use the API so you can create a class to
rub these things in in a nice way
so here's one example of how we can do
that so I can create a linked list data
structure and since in many cases the
driver accepts request for multiple
processes at the same time so it has to
access these kinds of lists in a safe
way which means it has to use some lock
and so again what I'm doing here is
accepting a potential lock as a template
parameter to the linked list so I am
defaulting that to fast music because
this is in tracked is the most common
type that is used but you can use some
other types that are available such as a
spin lock and the normal mutex and and
some others and so I want to have that
lock as part of my structure and then
whenever I'm going to do any operation
that changes the list
to acquire that lock whatever that may
be using the same auto lock structure
have shown previously in the right
example so here's a few examples of how
to implement this various function so
here's my pushback function accepting an
item of type T so that type T can be
anything but it must have at least entry
filled with the name entry this is
something I I require for this code to
compile otherwise the duck typing of C++
templates will not work and I'm calling
here initialized sorry insert a list
function which is a document kernel
function just utilizing that in an
easier manner so the client code would
just say pushback here's my my data
pointer and just just do it same goes
for push front and some other operations
I can have it's very easy if I need to
get to an to an item I can use the
containing record macro here to do for
me the offset calculations to get from
the internal structure to the top-level
structure which I care about so here's
an example it's supposed to be an
example so the example creates a data
structure machine besides that maybe
freezing it's better in this time and so
I have my own data structure let's call
it my data it can have anything but one
thing it must have is this list entry
structure that must be named entry
because my code relies on that and so
this would be the location with the
forward link and backwards name are
going to be stored and once I have that
I can declare a linked list of type my
data call it whatever and then just go
ahead and create an instance of that my
data I have to initialize my list and
then just call pushback for instance and
so it's very easy to work with that very
similar to something like STD linked
list or sorry to the list and so again I
have an opportunity here to create my
own standard library that suits my needs
I don't not creating something
the entire world necessarily but I'm
creating something that I'm eventually
going to pack in some library and then
I'll be able to use that in multiple
projects multiple drivers so just as we
have standard libraries in C++ in user
mode I'm creating my own standard
library and helpers in kernel mode for
my own driver projects okay so the last
example I want to show you is using some
more interesting features from C++ 11
and beyond
specifically templates or variadic
templates so Braddock templates I think
in one of the coolest features in C++
you could do really interesting stuff
with variadic templates and so I'm
talking here about something called
components what are actually components
and in this context so component is the
class that implements very various types
of functionality it supports several
interfaces perhaps and when I get an
interface pointer I can work with the
object without particular functionality
I can also ask the object do you support
a different type of functionality and
then if so I'm going to get a different
interface pointer to that particular
functionality and work with that
functionality so if you have been doing
any Windows development in user mode you
may have heard of something called the
component object model or com how many
Peter people have heard come just raise
of hands how many many people like comm
you can really you can okay two people
that's good usually okay call my wishy
that was dead already
but calm didn't die and actually made a
camp come back in Windows 8 because the
Windows runtime in Windows is based on
enhanced version of comp SOCOM is not
going to going away anytime soon so
don't worry about it however calm may
sound complex or may allude complex
because it has some complex politics
especially around threading models and
apartments when people hear that they
typically just want to jump out of the
window but the fundamentals of comma
very very simple it's about interface
based programming that's the first the
first prints
Ofcom and the second one is about
location transparency so I have no idea
where the component is just get me this
object with this class ID this is what
come actually has an and from from this
perspective come is a very good model
and so what if I want something like
this in my kernel code I want to create
kernel components and each one can
support different types of functionality
and I want reference counting to be
available because I don't want to track
each reference and maybe maybe handing
out these references or these pointers
to multiple threads and so I need
reference counting to be available and
so if I think about the standard C++
library I may think maybe I should
create something like shared pointer
however sure pointer does track
reference counting but it doesn't
provide any support for this squaring of
functionality and I certainly don't want
to use something like dynamic cast and
rtt I mean that's that's terrible I want
something that would be completely in
compile time and so again if you're
familiar with chrome Microsoft provides
several ways of implementing or creating
calm components using libraries such as
the active template library in the
Windows runtime library but however I
can't use them I can't use them in any
case I probably don't want to use them
because they're ugly
at least ATL is very ugly because it was
created many years ago and Radek
templates didn't exist and so the
solution let's create our own components
we can do it ourselves so let me show
you an example of how to do that so I
have this component the basic interface
for components I'm going to call that I
component this is very similar to the
iron known classic interface from
classic comm which provides to two
functionalities really the first one is
squaring for another interface for a
different kind of functionality based on
something called the interface ID now in
classic comm this is good but really
because I'm not writing something for
the entire world I'm going to use IDs
which has just simple numbers I don't
need to use real good although I can
and the other thing is managing a
reference count using this edge ref and
release functions so each rep should
increment the reference count and
release should document reference count
and if the reference count is zero the
objects should sort of terminate itself
so this is the base interface these are
all pure virtual functions and by the
way these annotations like the in here
and out PTR here these are called a
syntax annotation language or style
annotations and this is just a way for
providing metadata over parameters and
it can be used by so first as a human
user I can stand that this is in
parameter this is out and in some other
stuff that is available in sull but also
static analysis tools can go over my
code and see if I'm using properly
variables as the sanitation's indicate
so just to give you a brief idea of what
that is so this is I component this is
just an interface and so what I want to
be able to do is support reference
counting and support Crangle interfaces
so here's what I'm doing I'm creating a
class called component base which is
inheriting from multiple interfaces
provided as variadic templates and so I
can have as many interfaces as I want
and this public interfaces dot dot dot
actually inherits from all the
interfaces provided as part of this
component base and so what I want to
make sure that is that there is at least
one interface otherwise the class is
really useless and so I'm using static
assert here to make sure that the size
of the interfaces this is size of dot
dot dot which is the special size of
that works on parameter pack parameter
pack is the term useful the braddock
template parameters and so it must be
greater than zero otherwise I'm going to
get a compile time error so static
assert is very useful and you should use
it because it's all in compile time if
you can and so what I have in my class
here the basic thing is I have just a
reference count so I need to manage that
reference count I need to manage that
reference count
in a thread Safeway so here's EDF and so
if you've been if you try to implement
something released in C++ and use them
all you'll probably use something like
STD atomic of int or something like that
and do a plus plus and that's it
however we don't have atomic in the
kernel that again the stands lab is not
available so I'm calling the real
function or the real intrinsic behind
the covers called in windows in chalk
increment that allows us to do a a
thread-safe
plus plus on whatever variable that we
want same idea goes for release I'm
calling interlock decrement and then
looking at the new reference count and
if it's zero I'm going to just delete
the specific object of course that will
only work if I have proper override for
the delete operator and of course I'm
assuming here that the object will be
created by the appropriate new operator
that complements this little prattle of
course I have to provide all that later
on but EDF and release are fairly simple
so the most interesting function is
actually query interface so query
interface says hey mr. component here is
an interface ID are you supporting that
if so please give me back a pointer to
that interface if not just tell me that
you don't and so this is something we
need to do using variadic templates now
the trick in variadic templates like all
the ideas in compile time programming is
recursion we're going to use recursion
and so we're saying we have a list of
interfaces let's take the first one and
see if it's supported if not let's
remove that let's take the second one
and so on until we're out of interfaces
so this is a kind of the classic
template metaprogramming approach which
is required here and so this is my query
interface function that is provided by
the I component interface and need to
implement that so I'm going to use a
helper function called query interface
which is going to get this parameter
pack of types and so this query
interface which is shown here is
separating the interfaces
to the first and the rest so again this
is the the pod the recursive part and so
in this case what I'm doing I'm checking
that particular interface ID if it's the
ID requested by the client then that's
great I'm just returning static a so
that interface pointer to this and
providing the interface pointing back to
the crane interface function if not I'm
calling myself recursively with the rest
of the interfaces so again the now
interface is going to be the next
interface and so on and so like any good
recursion you have to stop it at some
point otherwise the compiler will go
into a crazy loop and burn your machine
and so you have to provide some stop
stopping mechanism and the trick here is
doing something like this saying
template and I can't really use an empty
brackets here that will not compile
properly because that would that
actually means the compiler Stan
specialization which is is not the case
so this actually works properly and this
would be called when there's zero
interfaces and so if I have no more
interfaces clearly I don't support it so
this would be my kind of stopping
mechanism for for the recursion and then
when we get back here from this query
interface we're going to get this result
if it's not null I'm going to increment
the reference count and return that
pointer to the client will start to
success otherwise I just return status
not found and so this is the trick here
and remember this recursion is only
happening at compile time so it's not
it's not a problem
it may take the compiler a few more
milliseconds to actually do this thing
but I don't care this code is generated
at compile time depending on the actual
interfaces I'm requesting or using so
here's an example here's a an example of
two interfaces I created I filter an i
process notify mean whatever they mean
they all inherit from I component my
sort of iron on interfacing adding their
own special special functions and then
when I want to create my component
implements these interfaces this is what
it's going to look like I'm going to
create my class it's called my filter
here and I'm going to inherit component
base and in the list of all the
interfaces that I actually support so
the list can be as long or as short as I
please but I do have to have at least
one interface otherwise that static
assert call will fail compilation and
then I can just implement this interface
in this case I'm just having a shortcut
here to create an instance of that a
class from outside using a static
function but typically they would it
will happen from an in another function
or another class which is typically
known as the class Factory as as its
implemented in classic comm but I've
kind of made some shortcut here just for
demonstration purposes and so now I can
create an instance and if I want to
check for a different functionality I
can use query interface I want the ID I
filter here and if it returns as not
null then this exists I can use it and
of course I have to make sure I call
release at the end and so naturally I'm
going to create a wry wrapper which
would be a smart pointer around
interface pointers which is very similar
to what you have in user mode in class
such as cecum PTR PTR that you have in
in the active template library for
instance so again you can do whatever
you want all all work with templates
such as these very attic templates and
meta programming with templates
everything works as expected because
these are just compiled time mechanisms
and so the fact that eventually this
code is going to be running in the
kernel has no real consequence I mean
it's just just code and the compiler
does the right thing and so with these
ideas I can actually create my own
robust framework for working with the
current don't have to continue working
will see my code is more robust because
I don't click anything and I have higher
abstraction mechanisms to do the things
that I want to do so once I have my
string class and my vector class and my
auto lock and all these things I'm
actually streamlining my work and don't
really have to worry about these things
and
need to worry about the actual
functionality I want to provide to my
driver don't want to worry about that
infrastructure which is a bit head a big
headache when working with the canner
you have to be careful but now don't
have to be very careful it tested that
it works for me in one driver then to
probably work for the next driver as
well and so if you are planning to work
in the kernel you think well I have to
go back to my sea roots and just work we
see and all the time then hopefully you
see that there is another way but you
can take from this also other ideas that
you can also implement in user mode of
course all these things that I've shown
you are mostly available in user mode as
well you don't have to perhaps overload
neon delete most of the time but of
course you can do that you can have
special type of requirement for memory
and allocations so I'll be available
later if you want to ask any questions
because we are currently out of time so
thank you for your attention
[Applause]